for the first time in history the
majority of Democrats identify as
liberal we will analyze what the
Democrats leftward lurch means for
American politics then New York City
Institute's socialist health care
Brooklyn resegregate sits schools and
the New York Times in the New York Times
theist articles ever frets about how the
government shutdown is affecting craft
beer producers know the horror
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
oh you know when this shutdown was just
affecting the my tax returns and border
security and the Coast Guard and when
that that I could handle that I could
handle but now that it's affecting craft
beer producers mr. president please you
have to end it and the madness I can't
if I can't drink new pretentious usually
not that great tasting beers what is
this country for what are we what are we
winning talk about a Pyrrhic victory
we'll get to that in a second but first
we have to talk about this new Gallup
poll showing that Democrats are lurching
to the left we talk about this all the
time in modern politics we say the
parties are becoming so polarized the
two sides the left and the right are
becoming so polarized that isn't exactly
true
one side is becoming polarized and it
seems to be the left it seems to be the
Democrats this new new poll from Gallup
shows most Democrats now identify as
liberal rather than moderate or
conservative you might say oh wow
Democrats are liberal Michael Wow this
is shocking new breaking stop the
presses
this actually is pretty surprising as
recently as 2008 only 38% of Democrats
identified as liberal others would say
oh I'm a moderate Democrat or even some
conservative Democrats this used to be
true of the Democrat Party there were
the progressives and there were the Blue
Dogs and the Blue Dog Democrats now I
guess the closest thing would be a guy
like Joe Manchin in West Virginia
although even he is basically a
progressive Democrat just on a few
issues he has to tack a little bit to
the right something like a Brit Kavanagh
has confirmation for instance otherwise
his constituents will throw him out of
office but now we're seeing the
Democrats or solidly for them for the
major part liberal this is the first
time since Gallup started tracking this
so it may be the first time in history
which I suspect it is Gallup been
tracking this since the 1990s but what
happens on the Republican side on the
Republican side now you see 73% of
Republicans identify as conservative so
many more Republicans identify as
conservative than Democrats identify as
liberal but what you've got a track here
is to change because this basically
hasn't changed at all it has
really changed since last year and even
if you go back to 2008 it's only ticked
up three percentage points back in 2008
70% of Republicans identified as
conservative whereas only 38% of
Democrats identified as liberal what
does this mean for American politics it
means that well while right now all the
talking heads New York Times the pundits
want you to focus on Trump how Trump is
changing American politics how he's
totally thrown the rulebook out it's all
different now the actual change that's
going on is on the left the actual
changes in the Democrat Party when you
look at how Donald Trump has governed
the country is there anything shocking
you coming completely out of left field
not really he's governing as a fairly
conservative Republican not totally
conservative Republican but fairly
conservative on some issues a little
more center-right on other as he's
solidly conservative there is nothing
new about that I guess he's more
conservative in many ways than george w
bush or his father george bush george HW
bush but is basically on line with
Ronald Reagan he's modeled his entire
campaign after Ronald Reagan make
America great again is a line he took
from Ronald Reagan although Ronald
Reagan said it were nicely cuz he had
the word less in front of it cuz let's
make America great again and Trump
obviously in the imperative do it do it
or else make America great again but
basically he's within the regular
conservative Republican mold the change
that's happening right now is a
generational change and that's why
you're seeing these new characters who
are entering Congress Alexandra Ocasio
cortes Rasheeda Talib Ilan Omar Julian
Castro not in Congress but you you see
all these up-and-coming Democrat
politicians who are much more left-wing
this is an age gap that don't be fooled
by the outlier which is Bernie Sanders
who's 350 years old this is a big age
gap and you're seeing a big fight
breaking out now within the Democrat
Party now how is this happening why all
of a sudden do you see even people like
Nancy Pelosi look conservative compared
to Alexandria Ocasio Cortes I don't
think it's some big seismic event that's
happened I think what's happening with
these people give them credit
give Alexandria Ocasio credit give Alon
Omar or whoever credit they are taking
progressivism to its logical conclusion
they are taking the Democrat Party to
its logical conclusion for decades now
the Democrats have been ferreting out
conservatives ferreting out moderates
and and these guys are taking it to
where it ultimately will go how does a
blue dog make any sense in today's
Democrat Party just just the that one
issue Hillary Clinton talked about it in
2008 that abortion should be safe legal
and rare this was Hillary trying to both
bring the progressives with her and say
we're gonna have a lot of legal abortion
but bring the conservatives with her to
the Blue Dogs and say but we shouldn't
have too much abortion
we shouldn't it's it's not a good thing
but we're gonna still have it if
abortion is morally similar to murder
why should it be legal if abortion is
not morally similar to murder if it's
just a tonsillectomy basically why
should it be rare that doesn't make a
whole lot of sense the the difference
here is that the GOP is intellectually
diverse the the right broadly has a lot
of pieces to it so you've got the neo
cons the Neo conservatives you've got
the traditionalists you've got the
libertarians you've got the religious
right you've got more populist elements
you've got all of these things going on
and they don't agree on everything they
kind of disagree on many issues on the
market on a free trade on religion on
culture they disagree on so many things
how do they all come together on the
right they came together largely because
of what was called the conservative
movement they came together largely
because of William F Buckley Jr who had
a philosophy or a practice called fusion
ISM where you fuse together these
different parts of what could be
conservatism into a coherent governing
coalition that's why we have
intellectual diversity what does the
Left have they just have progressivism
they have progressivism and the last
remnants of blue dog conservatives and
they've been going away for decades and
decades now now you're finally seeing
that turn that pivot and the majority
are progressive and liberal what is this
going to look like the first question it
raises is can the Democrat house push a
unit
fied agenda I don't know I mean
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez's first
congressional action when she got
elected was to take over Nancy Pelosi's
office and protest her own Speaker of
the House is that how is that gonna work
I mean right now just to use Ocasio as
sort of the the epitome of this new
young progressive coalition she's
pushing something called the green new
deal this amounts to a federal takeover
of the economy there's nothing short of
that this is the federal government
coming in and getting his hand in just
about every sector of the economy it
would ban fossil fuels in most things by
2030 it would mean that we have to power
our homes on renewable energies like
wind and solar which is a complete pipe
dream it is like powering them on
unicorns and gumdrops
it's a obscenely expensive it's not
efficient whatsoever but within this
green New Deal it sounds like it's just
talking about the environment there are
all these other insane progressive
platforms like a basic income so just
guaranteed money from the federal
government single-payer health care
socialist medicine and handouts to
left-wing groups and to unions and it
will cost an estimated forty trillion
dollars over the course of ten years
where's she gonna get the money she
doesn't know where she's gonna get the
money she doesn't have an answer to that
that is the kind of radicalism that
we're seeing but this is not I really
want to stress this this is not some new
crazy thing that Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez invented this has been building
as the logical conclusion of
progressivism since Woodrow Wilson and
we'll actually get to that on this day
in history today is the anniversary of
Woodrow Wilson announcing his 14 points
program at the end of World War one and
we're gonna see how that laid the
roadmap out for progressivism it brings
us exactly where we are
now our certain older Democrats a little
more conservative they are but they
don't make a lot of sense they're pretty
incoherent now we have a choice you know
we've got this government shutdown going
on and Cabot Phillips whom I love over
at campus reform he went out to college
campuses and he wanted to ask them what
they thought of Donald Trump's quotes on
McGill immigration and the government
shutdown and the
spin here is they weren't really Trump's
quotes they were quotes from Democrats
like Nancy Pelosi Barack Obama Hillary
Clinton and then the kids are all
shocked when they find out that the
quotes that they hate from Trump really
came from Democrats here is quotes here
President Trump talking about the need
for the southern border wall first quote
we should spend money to build a barrier
to prevent illegal immigrants from
coming in another quote we simply cannot
allow people to pour into the u.s.
undetected undocumented and unchecked
quote illegal immigration is wrong plain
and simple until the American people are
convinced we will stop future flows of
illegal immigration we'll make no
progress when you hear quotes like that
what's your reaction to them it's
divisive I think America is a land of
opportunity a place for inclusion I just
really think it's a kind of hateful
speech in general this is a negative
message like oh when he talks about like
illegal immigrants it's just one route
like to talk about people like that kind
of underlies a lot of things about like
discrimination and people and their
prejudiced prejudices and things like
that so I feel like that stuff is touchy
to talk about there are racial biases
kind of sort of deep embedded in there
in Oran I'd say it's more jingoist why I
think is I mean it's overall it's just
unacceptable I think just the way that
he's referring to people across the wall
is very dehumanizing so rhetoric like
that it's not helpful
no not at all what if I told you these
were from Chuck Schumer Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton how about that how about
that so the point of the video it's a
funny video because the point of the
video is that these kids all hate Donald
Trump and then so they hate anything he
says and then they find out it's
Democrats and then they're kind of
surprised that's funny that's totally
funny I think there's something more
interesting going on here though which
is what this video shows is not how kids
are hypocritical and how they just hate
Trump as a knee-jerk reaction I think
what it shows is how radically the
Democrat Party has changed in just 10
years or even less than 10 years
look politicians especially the Clintons
and Obama and Schumer and Pelosi they'll
just say whatever is politically
convenient right that's what they do
they change with the wind as long as
they follow their progressive base what
what this shows now I think is if even
if you tell those kids I mean you can
actually see some of them when as the
video goes on they say well okay
but this is what I think now and that
and that's really the point Chuck Shumer
of 2006 could never get elected with
this Democrat Party Hillary Clinton
could never get elected well I guess
that's just a perennial true statement
Hillary Clinton could never get elected
but she certainly couldn't get elected
now with her the position she held in
2008 that's this is the same thing going
on all throughout the Congress and
throughout the country
this party this democrat party is much
further left it's not a shared problem
it's not a Oh both sides are to blame
it's not it is the Democrat Party
uniquely is moving far to the left and
frankly maybe it's not the worst thing
in the world it's bad because it poses a
danger to the country if they get into
power but it's good in that it gives
Americans a choice they have a clear
choice at least they're being honest we
used to say oh these Democrats they're
hiding their true objectives which are
socialism or you know socialist health
care or their true objectives on
marriage which is to redefine marriage
or their true objective on abortion
which is abortion on demand without
apology and now they're being honest
about it this is in many ways the point
of the conservative movement when Bill
Buckley started it in the 1950s was to
give Americans a choice not an echo
that's what Barry Goldwater said but
when he was running for president now we
have that choice a Trump tonight is
going to be giving a speech on the
government shutdown and border security
he's going to be giving a speech now the
Democrats want to give a response to
that speech Chuck and Nancy want to give
a response to that speech unprecedented
for an oval office speech a lot of
conservatives are complaining about this
a lot of Democrats are complaining the
Trump is giving his speech in the first
place I think it's a great thing I think
this is one it's a good thing because
it's reality TV this is the politics
we've elected but - it's good for our
democratic system to hear both sides and
at least we have an honest choice and if
we go down for it which I hope we don't
at least you can say well people were
presented the information and
unfortunately they voted away our great
country some lefties just on the Trump
speech itself are very upset that Donald
Trump is speaking from the Oval Office
every president gives oval office
addresses and the news networks always
cover it but because the mainstream
media uniquely hate Donald Trump they're
actually calling for the speech either
not to be
covered or even to be censored here are
that dynamic duo from CNN Fredo Cuomo
and Don Lemon do you think it should be
I don't know a delay of some sort and
then you can because people believe it
people the president will say what he
has to say people will believe it
whether the facts are true or not
I guess that's a chance you take with
any president but yes and this one is
different
and then by the time the rebuttals come
on we've already promoted propaganda
possibly and unless he gets up there and
he tells the truth
he has his right to make the argument to
the American people and by the way
wanting barriers along the border is not
propaganda no no it's not a moral fact
it's not wrong facts of do you think it
should be I don't know a delay of some
sort chris Cuomo's face is do you want
to delay or some sort and you see his
eyebrows furrow I think that they
employed Don Lemon at CNN just to make
Chris Cuomo look reasonable so is there
any and at least Chris Cuomo to his
credit says no we shouldn't delay it but
that's Don Lemon Don Lemon representing
the new school of the Democrat Party
Chris Cuomo the whole Cuomo family
representing an older school of the
Democrat Party Chris Cuomo is brother is
Andy Cuomo is the governor of New York
but their father Mario Cuomo was the
governor I think for you know 75 years
in New York very long term governor he
was a likely Democrat presidential
candidate he's actually the one who
invented the Democrat stands the
moderate Democrat stance on abortion
which is I support abortion even though
I'm opposed to it personally again which
makes no sense why are you opposed to it
personally because it's morally
equivalent to murder so why do you
support it publicly because you don't
care if we kill all those little black
babies you just don't want your precious
little babies to be killed doesn't make
a lot of sense but you see that right
there on on CNN that difference between
the New Democrats of Don Lemon the old
Democrats of Chris Cuomo and those New
Democrats they're not just calling for
progressive programs they're calling for
censorship they're calling for delays
they're saying this guy is different so
we've got to treat him differently the
network's by the way are playing into
this it's not just the histor
erekle people on CNN it's the the
mainstream news networks are taking
Democrat talking points hook line and
sinker in the run-up to tonight's speech
set to make his case for a border wall
as the government shutdown enters its
18th day Democrats fighting back saying
the speech will be nothing but malice
and misinformation Democrats are clearly
concerned about the nation only hearing
one side of this argument and not
getting the facts they are demanding
equal time tonight to respond saying in
a statement quote if the president's
past statements are any indication it
will be full of malice and
misinformation Democrats have vowed to
fight any attempts to bypass Congress
with legal challenges hold on let me
also allege that if the president's past
statements or any indication will it be
addressed tonight will be full of quote
misinformation and now malison and
misinformation I didn't see that one
coming did you see that one coming
what's astounding about this is not that
the networks are playing up Democrat
talking points but the Democrat talking
point here is not about something that
has happened it's not reacting to a
speech that has already been given it's
predicting the future it's predicting
what the man will say saying you know in
the future Donald Trump is gonna speak
with malice and misinformation and then
the networks ABC CBS NBC those guys are
covering this as though this is not only
fact but but but fact in the sense that
it has already happened and hasn't
already happened it's happening tonight
but they're already covering it because
whatever the Democrats say must be true
even if it hasn't happened yet so
they're all playing into this we'll see
what happens tonight we might get a
speech and a response if we do that's
fine we might just get the speech from
the Oval Office
it'll only last about seven or eight
minutes it will be a typical Oval Office
broadcast I love it I'm glad that we're
having this this is a debate
fundamentally about not just are we
gonna protect this board or are we gonna
have a wall are we gonna have this
budget or we're gonna open the
government
this debate in its essential components
boils down to do we still love our
country or do we not still love our
country I'm not speaking hyperbolically
this is not some exaggeration here do we
love our country or not there you have
one side saying that we have a serious
problem
in historic drug epidemic because if
drugs pouring over our border a lot of
crime people being killed people being
raped according to fusion and Amnesty
International 60 to 80 percent of women
and girls across that southern border
illegally are raped and sexually
assaulted you've got the question of
whether this country can decide who gets
to access its welfare programs who gets
to access its schools what language
people in this country are going to
speak who gets to vote in this country
who who is counted for the
representation in the Congress right now
the representation in the Congress is
based on the census it's based on legal
and illegal alike so you've got even if
in certain places illegal aliens aren't
voting they're being counted for
representation do we get to govern
ourselves do we love our country do we
want to protect our country and build a
wall and deal with border security or as
the Democrats want do we want to let our
country be washed away because we don't
like it very much do we want a totally
new people to come in a totally new
culture to come into this country a
totally new system of government where
we don't get to protect our borders
where we don't only count the rights or
the votes rather of citizens where we
don't only use taxpayer money to protect
citizens to protect the people here who
are paying into it
who are our countrymen who are tied to
us by the bonds of countrymen and
citizens which is it do we love our
country or do we want a different
country do we want our country and to
protect our country do we want to
abolish the idea of our country all
together and just have something new
with open borders or whatever which is
it that's the debate it's a real debate
I'm not I'm not trying to get here on my
soapbox and just vilify the other side
although I think the other opinion the
the opinion of of not protecting our
country should be vilified those are
actually the the stakes
that's the honest debate we're gonna
have and I hope we have it totally
honestly I hope that the networks cover
Trump's speech and I hope that the
Democrats give whatever response they
possibly can I think they should get
their awful ideas out in the open
because I think that this country still
will choose to love itself I think this
country still will choose to protect
itself I think this country still will
choose to be a country I think
ultimately we're
Wiccans have the winning hand here we
shouldn't be afraid of erring Democrats
views in public it really helps us when
we air their radical views we show the
American people who they are and and we
can reject them both at the ballot box
and in terms of the pressure that's
coming from this government shutdown the
the way that you know that the
government shutdown is going pretty well
for Trump and the Republicans is how
it's being covered in the New York Times
today I try never to cover the New York
Times but I suppose I have to every once
in a while just to see what the other
side thinks the lead article in the New
York Times the number one article when
you go to their website is this quote
shut down ripples across nation
affecting farmers homeowners even craft
brewers so that now now they've since
changed the headline when you go to the
article itself so they probably realized
how absurd that is because you know not
craft brewers no no of course not that's
ridiculous
by the way how is this affecting craft
brewers it's because the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms and
Explosives is not approving new beer
labels so you can only have the seven
zillion hipster Brooklyn beers that are
already on the market you're not gonna
get that's seven zillion then one until
the government reopens I'm sorry get you
can get through it talk to your
therapist talk to your friends and loved
ones also mortgage applications are
being delayed because the federal
government is involved in mortgage
business public companies now are having
some trouble possibly raising capital
because the federal government is so
heavily regulating the economy the
Secret Service obviously is not being
paid for its work and farmers right now
are having trouble applying for federal
subsidies because parts of the federal
government are shut down
few people are really feeling this pain
there was this poll that came out from
Rasmussen six percent of Americans say
this shutdown is really hurting them
21 percent of Americans don't know the
government is shut down those are good
numbers for us those are good numbers
for Donald Trump we're on day 17 right
now this is the second longest
government shutdown ever and yet
nobody's really feeling the pain from
this for those who are for the people
applying for mortgages and the in the
craft beer people and the farm subsidy
people this raises a question that's
very uncomfortable actually for the left
which is why is the federal government
so heavily involved in all of those
things why is the federal government
heavily involved in craft beer why is
the federal government in why are we
giving all these subsidies to farmers to
to pick only certain industries over
other industries why is the what why is
that
maybe this government shutdown as I
predicted before it happened is showing
us how much government we don't need as
Ronald Reagan said you'll be surprised
how much government you'll never miss
maybe it's saying well as we're having a
big debate here between Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez who wants the government
basically to take over the whole economy
and conservatives who say we should
deregulate we should shrink the size of
the government we should shrink the
onerous regulations on people I think
this government shutdown is showing us
which side should win in that argument
we don't need all this government it
doesn't it's it it's onerous it's we
have a way overinflated bureaucracy it's
racking up enormous debt that will be a
drag on our economy that is a
generational tax and generational theft
why do we need all of that the Trump
administration by the way has directed
the IRS in case this government shutdown
goes through March and April which it
certainly almost certainly will not but
if it does it's directed the IRS to pay
people's tax refunds out which raises
another question if the government can
just arbitrarily run and stop things
even during a shutdown then what is this
shutdown what's what is this about it's
about showing how unwieldy the federal
government is and and it's about raising
this question of why won't the the
Democrats fund our war security so much
of this thing has been malleable this
will stay open this won't stay open this
can this can the parks can remain open
your text returns will come in your
flights will be fine then what is this
really about it's about this central
question why won't Democrats protect our
country we've got another crazy story
from the New York Times today because
I'm a glutton for punishment I'm a
masochist over Brooklyn schools
resegregate a black so many schools and
and black curriculum specifically black
curriculum we'll get to that we'll get
to Bill DeBlasio put pushing socialist
health care in New York and we'll also
get to this day in history but first I'm
sorry
you have to go to daily wire.com it's
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the end
reply pin show you have the Ben Shapiro
show you to ask questions in the mailbag
you get mount Walsh you get to ask
questions in backstage you get another
Kingdom you get so much stuff but this
is what really matters this right here
because when the craft beer factory is
shut down
when Brooklyn hipsters with stupid
mustaches
can't sip overpriced subpar beer they
are going to weep and then you're going
to get these craft leftist tiers
tumblers and they're really good they're
really local brewed they taste they
taste vaguely of kombucha they're your
they're really good this is the only
vessel that can handle them the only
vessel approved by the FDA which by the
way is shut down so you're not going to
get any new vessels approved by the FDA
any time soon to handle those left is
tears go to daily wire comm get it we'll
be right back
also in the New York Times today and
major article right there in the front
part of the website quote I love my skin
why black parents are turning to afro
centric schools before you could
basically dismantle this entire argument
for resegregate just from the headline
but let's go on it opens up while New
York City schools are deeply segregated
some black families are choosing an
alternative to integration by the way
just to get you through that the
alternative to integration is
segregation so they're saying as black
families are choosing segregation I know
you know the New York Times in May
they're a little confused about language
they're not so smart anymore but that's
what they're saying the same black
families are choosing segregation the
first paragraph quote I love myself the
group of mostly black children shouted
in unison I love my hair I love my skin
when it was time to settle down their
teacher raised her fist in a Black Power
salute the students did the same and the
room hushed as children filed out of the
cramped School Auditorium on their way
to class they walked by posters of Colin
Kaepernick and Harriet Tubman so because
they're the same did you know that Colin
Kaepernick who's a schmucky left-wing
mediocre football player who decided to
cash in and make zillions of dollars on
race hustling that guy he's the same as
Harriet Tubman a gun-wielding Republican
who transported slaves through the
Underground Railroad to their freedom
Colin Kapernick schmucky Nike spokesman
Harriet Tubman one of the great heroes
of American history transport slaves to
their freedom they're the same thing
that's why they walk past the photos of
them right on the same on the same wall
the article goes on though Afrocentric
schools have a uniquely comprehensive
approach many of New York's 1,800 public
schools have specialized themes there
are engineering math and culinary
schools
others have albanian or do or Bengali
bilingual programs
and some are just about how cool blacks
are and and how you should love yourself
and how great that schmucky Nike
spokesman is unbelievable the way that
they make these category errors on the
left they're saying look some schools
specialize in engineering
some schools specialize in math and some
schools specialize in radical black
racial ideology those aren't the same
thing those so engineering math
literature performing arts those are
academic categories black is the color
of the skin those are not like
categories it's actually the you know
the the left gets everything exactly
backwards so with this new resegregate
program mixes is the worst of the left
race hustling identity politics and the
self-esteem movement and replacing
education with ideological
indoctrination the problem with this
this starts right from the first words
of the article I love my skin why why do
you love your skin I don't love my skin
I like oh I'm sorry I shouldn't I love
my skin because it protects my body and
keeps me from diseases and keeps me from
infections and means that I'm not just a
walking hunk of raw flesh destined to
die within minutes so I like my skin for
that reason what do you like your skin
what do you love your skin it's your
skin there's nothing that to love about
that you even look at all that I love
myself I love my hair I love my skin my
hair has served me well I'm not an
Adonis of a man so any luck I've had in
picking up the ladies I can probably
attribute to my to my locks that's my
really probably my main physical gift I
don't love my hair what do you love your
hair why it what it what the left does
is it is idolatry it makes idols out of
meaningless things and it perverts
therefore not just religion not just
really what we talked about with
idolatry but therefore culture and
therefore politics don't love your skin
don't love your hair don't love yourself
what do you love yourself there's this
whole movement now the self the
self-esteem movement is what birth did
but it's the self love movement the self
care movement and the reason that people
are drawn to this you
is because of a god-shaped hole in your
heart I hate to use what has become a
cliche but it's because people long
naturally for the transcendental for the
metaphysical for the divine we realize
to use technical terms that in this
world everything is contingent things
decay things die
nothing is enduring and lasting in our
physical world and so we long for
metaphysical things we long for God we
long for the unmoved mover who is not
contingent who is the creator of the
universe that's what we long for all of
human history every culture every
civilization has longed for that that's
a part of our human nature and what what
either people who are trying to play and
deceive you or very ignorant people do
is that they try to replace that
transcendental longing with physical
things they say instead of turning that
love that you should have for God for
the metaphysical you should turn that in
on yourself
but that is the sin of pride I mean that
is why pride is the queen of all sins
that's why Satan falls like lightning
from heaven because of the sin of pride
this is why the image that john milton
gives us of satan is that satan births
from his own pride from his own
narcissism from his own head he births
sin and then he has an incestuous
relations with his narcissistic
daughters sin and that creates death
this is the image this is what pride
does it's why for all of the history of
our civilization we talk about pride is
the queen of all sins that we now have
pride parades not just for gay pride but
for all other sorts of probably we now
have the self love the self care self
love self care pride or as they manifest
themselves in our culture a terrible
terrible thing don't do it if you try to
just love yourself as the be-all and
end-all you will hate yourself and you
will hate the world and you will be very
miserable if you try to be proud you
will be very miserable because pride
goeth before destruction and a haughty
spirit before a fall these are not just
words scribbled by some very old Jews
this is eternal and enduring wisdom this
is why by the way the people who engage
in this race hustling why the people who
engage in this
self-segregation or miserable it's white
their politics has become coarse and
miserable and they screech and they
scream and they yell out and they wear
simulacra of genitalia on their heads
it's why the left can't laugh anymore
it's why it has no humor it's because
essentially there is a sin of pride that
they are embracing it's a very bad we
should tell them not to do this we
should tell them that they can't
segregate themselves that they can't go
off and and I'm not just talking about a
black school I'm talking about the
segregation that occurs throughout all
of our culture through these constantly
dividing disparate intersectional groups
tell them no sorry ain't gonna happen
you're the color of your skin doesn't
make you special you in yourself are not
perfect you're not you're not totally
perfected you're not utterly deserving
of love you are defected and you
therefore need love and you need grace
and you need mercy and you need justice
and you need the transcendental that
that's the only way we're gonna do it I
know it's very unpopular to talk about
things in this way in our very
materialist shallow society but it's the
only way we're gonna get back to any
sense of the normal also in New York I
guess this is a New York heavy show
today bolshevik bill de blasio the mayor
over there has jumped the gun forget
Ocasio cortez forget bernie sanders
forget all of the other socialist
healthcare schemes Bill de Blasio's just
doing it himself URI is on Morning Joe
you are about to do something pretty
remarkable in New York City why don't
you tell us about it yeah Joe this has
never been done before in this country
in this kind of comprehensive way it's
going to be for the first time a
guarantee of health care we're gonna
guarantee health care for New Yorkers
who need it and we have now in New York
City something that we can build on we
have a public option that we're ready to
make much bigger a public health
insurance option that can reach the
hundreds of thousands that are right now
not in any kind of health insurance we
also have a way to provide direct health
care to a lot of our neighbors who
happened
be undocumented there's still part of
our community they need health care
their families need health care we
recognized that obviously health care is
not just in theory a right we have to
make it in practice a right and we're
doing something about that here in this
city and so there's so much wrong here
health care is not a right there's no
there's no right you don't what would it
even mean for health care to be a right
health care requires medicine health
care requires discovery innovation it
requires doctors labor it requires
expensive equipment it requires visits
to hospitals how on earth could that be
a right what would it if health care is
our right then what is a right a right
is meaningless it doesn't have any
meaning health care is a is a commodity
health care is a good and a service that
we want and goods and services cost
things and so the question Bill DeBlasio
is honestly trying to answer is how do
you pay for health care he's using
dishonest language of rights to do it
but there's a lot wrong there the
trouble with socialist medicine is the
trouble with socialism eventually you
run out of other people's money the
other fear here is that ultimately when
the government has enough control over
that sector of the economy it has
control over your healthcare and
therefore it has control over your
healthcare decisions it can decide if
you get the surgery or you don't get the
surgery it can decide if you get the
medicine or you don't get the medicine
it can decide nobody gets the medicine
and you have nothing that you can do
about it because the government controls
the whole thing that's one of the great
fears of socialist health care all of
that said I would be much more
comfortable if every mayor in every
liberal town in America did exactly what
Bill DeBlasio did because then maybe we
wouldn't need this national
one-size-fits-all solution if it could
be the case that all these liberal towns
that want to destroy themselves that
want to damage their citizens and they
want to hurt their economies and they
want to hurt their healthcare systems if
they want to make a socialist medicine
and they just do it and they leave me
alone I can deal with that I can live
with that it pains me because New York
is my is my native place it's my home
and so that pains me to see that
happened to my own place but but that
would be much better than if we had some
one-size-fits-all all of a sudden we
take over a sixth of the entire American
economy now the trouble here for
socialist healthcare
we've been lamenting this for a long
time as as conservatives is when these
things start to gain steam once you see
cities start to pass these things they
take over very quickly
New York is often a leader here you'll
remember you in the olden days I'm old
enough to remember you used to be able
to smoke in restaurants and hotels and
things like that
then all of a sudden one day you
couldn't and in New York was the first
one to institute these smoking bans on a
wide scale in a big place and all of a
sudden it took off all over the country
you could see this happening now so
you've got the good part of federalism
which is it protects us from the wildest
left-wingers but then over time it
builds consensus this is one of the
purposes of federalism and so you could
see that come to the national level I'll
talk about this a little more when we
get to Woodrow Wilson this an element of
the conservative movement has always
been lost causes there I was listening
to a symposium from the New Criterion on
Russell Kirk and Russell Kirkwood talked
about this that conservatism is not
primarily about profit and making a
profit and profit profiting all the time
it's really fundamentally about loss
it's about looking at what we've lost
what we can still gather as a remnant
from our civilization which is going
away from us which we're losing
especially in this modern era and and
that's what I'm looking at when I see
Bill DeBlasio say these things when I
see national candidates get a lot of
play because they talk about socialist
health care you think gosh this is not
looking good for us this is not looking
good down the road we got to fight it
even though we know the deck is stacked
against us even though we know we're
probably gonna lose but maybe we won't
lose this fight we'll see what happens
when we get to Woodrow Wilson I do have
to point out Ruth Bader Ginsburg the
left-wing justice on the Supreme Court
she is now very old she's in her 80s she
has now missed two days at the job she's
missed two days at the court missed oral
arguments this is the first time in her
entire career that that's the case she
was nominated by Bill Clinton I believe
in 93 so she's been on the court for a
long time and she has missed it because
she's recovering from cancer surgery now
she's previously miss she's had two
prior
cancer surgeries in 1999 and 2009 she's
never missed a day on the court for that
this recent one
they removed lumps from her lungs this
was after she cracked some ribs from a
fall things are not looking good for
Ruth Bader Ginsburg and this I I wish
her well I'm not even gonna make jokes
about her dying I think that's important
but this will just show you what 2019
looks like if worth Bader Ginsberg's
health does not recover if she finds
that she has to retire from the court or
or or her maker decides that she has to
retire from the court then that is going
to be the dominant story of 2019 there
will be nothing else we saw this with
the Cavanaugh confirmation hearing we're
seeing this now with the possibility of
Ruth Bader Ginsburg leaving the court
because the Congress and the executive
to some degree have given so much of
American governing power over to the
supreme court the Congress constantly is
is deferring to the court to make laws
and then the executive has done this to
george w bush when he signed to mccain
feingold which was awful legislation to
regulate political speech he even
intimated that he thought it might be
unconstitutional that he was leaving it
for the court to decide all three
branches of government have the duty to
uphold the Constitution all three
branches of government should stop
things when they seem unconstitutional
and unfortunately the Congress in the
executive haven't done that the court
really matters also because the court
has so run roughshod over the
Constitution for so very long that that
now there is a movement for the past 50
years or so of returning to the
Constitution of being more rigidly
accurate of being textualist
interpreting the text to mean what it
meant when it was written this is going
to be the major fight it looks like
Cavanaugh is a little bit squishy
unfortunately Roberts we know is a big
squish but if a president Trump were to
replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg the
left-wing Supreme Court justice with an
originalist that would be a huge switch
in the swing of the court it would be it
the story if you thought Kavanaugh was
bad that was a cakewalk compared to what
you'll see in 2019 so a lot of this year
and
politics we're talking about the wall
we're talking about shutdowns we're
talking about a 2020 Democrat primary
we're talking about all more tax reform
maybe entitlement reform all of that is
gonna go out the window if we're worth
better Ginsburg is off the court it will
all be about the court so gear up if you
if you liked the Cavanaugh fight get
ready for this one I mean it was so
bloody it was so brutal but I will point
out it was very good for Republicans it
was a very good for Donald Trump
if the midterms had been held right
after that Cavanaugh fight we would have
we would have kept the house it's it was
so good for us in public opinion polls
so we'll see what happens but as with
everything in the Trump presidency
get ready for a crazy reality show this
is gonna this is simply going to take it
season three or season four as it as it
is it's gonna be a totally at the next
level this day in history this day in
history in 1918 Woodrow Wilson announced
his fourteen points for the end of World
War one so they were in World War one
Woodrow Wilson in many ways the inventor
of modern progressivism in American
politics he announces his 14 points for
what was going to happen after the war
and how the World Order was going to
move forward this was assailed by
conservatives who pointed out rightly
that god only needed 10 points Woodrow
Wilson needed 14 this you see whenever
these things go on longer and longer you
you realize that they're getting worse
and worse look at the Constitution of
the United States it fits onto that
beautiful yellow two piece of parchment
look at the Constitution of the European
Union I think it's about seven Sicilian
pages long when these things go on they
get to in the detail they get to
technocratic they're probably not going
to work they're probably not going to
protect human freedom he announced his
points all around the world he was
dropping in his propaganda the sticking
point was the 14th point which
established the League of Nations a
general Association of Nations must be
formed under specific covenants for the
purpose of affording mutual guarantees
of political independence and
territorial integrity to great and small
States alike the American people didn't
like this especially conservatives and
Republicans didn't like this they didn't
like the idea that we were giving up our
sovereignty to these super national
international
institutions that we're going to now
govern us we were no longer going to be
a free country you heard this all the
time in this era in the Progressive Era
oh the presidency it's too big for one
man oh the Constitution is not fit for
these complicated times does that sound
familiar you have had since the era of
Wilson progressives trying to push
socialist health care trying to push all
of the same programs that they're
pushing now and the reason I bring this
up the reason this is so important at
this moment in politics is because at
that time it was a lost cause
conservative cause the cause of freedom
the cause of our country was a lost
cause you saw socialism lighting a fire
all around the world
you saw the Russian royal family fall
you saw it you saw communists take over
what then became the Soviet Union you
saw it
a burning like a disease throughout
Europe you saw communists in the streets
and socialists in the streets in America
it looked you heard a journalist say
when they looked at the Soviet Union
I've seen the future and it works this
was simply it this was the way to
progress there was no stopping it
and then we stopped him and then the
Conservatives stopped when when the
conservative movement came around Bill
Buckley said that a conservative is one
who stands with word history yelling
stop and when that conservative movement
came around it was a lost cause
progressivism was gonna win communism
would win the Soviet Union would remain
strong conservatism was a lost cause it
was made fun of mocked as a lost cause
by the media by leftist academics and
politicians and then we won and then the
Berlin Wall fell down and then we
rejected Woodrow Wilson's fourteen
points and and then we would actually it
ended up killing Woodrow Wilson he
suffered a stroke he was so outraged and
shocked when we when the United States
rejected entrance into the League of
Nations when we wouldn't give up some of
our national sovereignty in that way
these are lost causes they were lost
causes all the time they've been a lost
cause socialism has been a lost cause
for conservatives for a hundred years
and yet we've made it a hundred years
maybe we can make it a hundred more so I
wouldn't let it get you down it is a
lost cause we're looking we're looking
the the death right in the barrel we're
looking anti-americanism right right in
the barrel and we're probably going to
lose except maybe we won't and that's
why we keep fighting because we've what
we won those battles before and
I'd love the president Trump is sticking
strong in this shutdown we should stick
strong on all of these things and if we
go down so what we gave it a good fight
but maybe we'll win we've done it before
ok that's our show today we've got a lot
more to get to but too bad tune in
tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you